on passe donc à l'écho du jeudi ce soir
plan social pour alcatel et puis
commerces de proximité et nouveau départ
pour le groupe génération entreprise à
l'assemblée la chronique échos
la semaine du commerce de proximité
vient de se terminer le quatrième
édition qui a permis de faire le lien
entre la population et les commerçants
locaux à valérie auribeau pour ce
reportage
savoir-faire lien social emplois locaux
et développement durable samedi 13
octobre dernier pour la quatrième
édition de la journée nationale du
commerce de proximité de l'artisanat et
du centre ville les commerçants
d'elancourt ont mis en avant leurs
atouts et en ont profité pour proposer
de nouvelles prestations ce soir on fait
une soirée vaines
donc il ya des massages le salon sera
décoré de bougies
avec de la musique de yoga ont c'est un
autre aspect de la coiffure dans ce
salon les habitués sont attachés à la
proximité quirinal et disponibilité sont
embêterait de devoir aller plus loin
parce que la justice a mis à pied c'est
vrai que c'est pratique que ce soit pour
les à la poste ou au supermarché
je suis je suis bien ici voie d'avoir
tous les commerces à disposition à côté
de chez soi ou à côté du travail c'est
quand même c'est primordial à mon avis
plutôt que ceux des de devoir se
déplacer à des kilomètres 35 voitures
oui c'est très important louis le
mauvais temps ne sera pas parvenue à
freiner la synergie entre les
commerçants près d'une trentaine d'entre
eux ont participé à l'opération cette
année au fur et à mesure notre puce de
commerçants qui participent donc c'est
quand même nettement mieux pour nous
parce qu'effectivement c'est vraiment
une vraie cohésion commercial
prochain rendez vous le 1er décembre
pour le marché de noël
nous parlons donc du commerce de
proximité on va continuer à en parler
avec vous à l'iss pour cette chronique
etc au commerce de proximité ce qu'il se
porte bien ce commerce de proximité on
va écouter ça défend un petit plus des
endroits dans l'agglomération voilà
exactement mais généralement il ya quand
même des groupes des réseaux qui sont
mis en place notamment par la chambre de
commerce pour un petit peu favorisé les
réseaux d'entrepreneurs un nouveau
groupe vient de se créer dans le centre
yvelines exclusivement composé de
commerçants nous avons assisté au
lancement on regarde ce reportage
on marchés ont accéléré un petit peu le
pas quand vous êtes trop au fait
quelqu'un quelque chose mais pour juste
des caresses base de lier
des exercices de théâtre pour faire
connaissance c'est la première fois que
les membres du nouveau groupe plateaux
du centre yvelines se rend compte 22
groupes existent déjà dans le
département la particularité de celui ci
il est composé exclusivement de
commerçants
jusqu'à présent nous accompagnons
uniquement des industriels industrie
services à l'industrie et aujourd'hui
nous proposons d'accompagner les
commerçants commerces de proximité et
et services à la personne par don via la
méthodologie plateau le commerce de
proximité ne bénéficient pas
accompagnement de ceux de ce genre c'est
un peu nouveau les réseaux d'entreprise
pour les commerçants il nous semblait
important que eux aussi et 7 me keep
pouvoir apprendre à travailler ensemble
une méthode basée sur l'accompagnement
de dirigeants d'entreprises par des
cadres de grandes entreprises créées une
dizaine d'années à l'initiative de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles le réseau plato permet un
échange d'outils d'expérience et surtout
de contacter les groupes sont suivis par
un cadre pendant deux ans éviter la
solitude
être dans les changes est-ce que vous en
attendez et ce qui est économiquement ça
peut vous aider
je ne sais pas encore économiquement
mais là ça a l'air d'être bien partie au
moins de 2 je pense que c'est plus
j'attends plus des des informations d
aider des personnes qui sont installés
depuis bien plus longtemps que moi doit
qui ont un recul plus important
pour faire partie d'un groupe il faut se
rapprocher de la chambre de commerce ici
les commerçants se sont acquitté d'un
droit d'entrée de 2000 euros pour les
deux années de suivi du groupe avec en
moyenne un rendez vous par mois alors
c'est donc comme ça qu'on favorise le
commerce de proximité si vous avez suivi
ce report verra si ça marche voir si ça
fonctionne effectivement sur sur la
durée on va changer de sujet c'est
beaucoup moins amusant pour contrôler
ses ailes le plan social du côté
d'alcatel oui on en parlait en début
d'émission ce plan social annoncé par
alcatel lucent qui va supprimer donc
1430 postes en france soit 16 % de son
effectif dans l'hexagone déjà fin
juillet le groupe avait annoncé la
suppression de 5000 hommes de 5000
emplois pardon à travers le monde le
site de vélizy est concerné par cette
annonce et vendredi se tient le comité
central d'entreprise sur ce site où sera
présentée la déclinaison de ce plan par
alcatel lucent france et ses
conséquences donc pour les emplois de
vélizy nous vous tiendrons bien
évidemment informés ans des suites de
cette annonce le point lors du 7-8
week-end qui vous sera présenté par
catherine cela tôt ce sera dès demain à
partir de 18 heures la réunion avec la
direction pour alcatel se tenant en
début d'après midi